في هذه المنازل في منطقه المشاعله في جنوب
مدينه دير البلح اغارت الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه فجر اليوم على بنايه لعائله
فياض استشهد بداخلها ما يقارب من 11 شهيدا
وصلوا مستشفى شهداء الاقصى عباره عن اشلاء
بالاضافه الى عدد كبير من المصابين من
المنازل المجاوره لهذا البيت الذي تم
تدميره بشكل كامل المواطنين هنا شهود
العيان الذين تحدثوا لنا قالوا بان الغاره
الاسرائيليه كانت غاره قويه جدا وقد دمرت
المنزل بشكل كامل وتم انتشال جثث لشهداء
من هنا وفعلا وصلوا الى مستشفى شهداء
الاقصى جل هؤلاء الشهداء الذين ارتقوا
جراء هذه الغاره الاسرائيليه على جنوب دير
البلح هم من النازحين الذين كانوا يقطنون
في هذه الخيام البسيطه الذي تم انشائها
بالقرب من هذا المنزل المدمر لعائله فياض
الساعه 213 دقيقه سمعنا الانفجار فاهم كيف
صار زعيق وسوات طلعنا نجري من الدور المهم
زي ما انت شايف عنا استهدفوا بيت ابن عمي
بشير فياض اللي استشهد هو بشير وبنته
واولاده اثنين باقي الشهداء والاصابات
نازحين هول نزحوا من منطقه خانيونس منطقه
الزنه اللي قالت اسرائيل اللي بتقول لخن
يونس وبتقول للبريد وللمغص ول خانيونس
ورفع وا و و توجهوا للمناطق الامنه وهذه
من خارطه اسرائيل انها منطقه امنه توجهت
المنطقه الامنه زي ما انت شايف بوهم عباده
هي الحيوانات هي رجلين رجلين مقطعات ش
تفرضى هذا الحيوان هذا المنزل تحول الى
كومه من الركان بعد غاره جويه اسرائيليه
هنا دمرت هذا المنزل وعدد من المنازل
المجاوره ارتقى عدد ايضا اخر من النازحين
الذين جاؤوا فارين من القصف الاسرائيلي
على خان يونس هنا لدى اقربائهم من عائله
فياض ولكن الغاره الاسرائيليه اودت بحياه
عدد كبير من الفلسطينيين الذين كانوا من
اصحاب المنزل ومن النازحين ايضا لديهم
اشرف ابو عمره لقناه الجزيره دير البلح
وسط قطع
غزه